aquí tenemos un rumbo a bs
y lo que queremos probar es que hace es
perpendicular a bb o sea que las
diagonales son perpendiculares vamos a
acordarnos que es un rombo para empezar
un rombo es un caso particular de un
paralelogramo o sea en un rombo los
pares de lados opuestos son paralelos a
de aquí sería paralela a abc y además a
b a b sería paralela a cede pero un
rombo es un paralelogramo más especial
además de pedir que los pares de lado
supuesto sean paralelos también tenemos
que pedir que todos los lados me dan lo
mismo o sea que a b b c c de idea me dan
todo lo mismo muy bien ahora como te
comentaba un rombo es un paralelogramo y
ya sabemos muchas cosas de los paralelo
gramos por ejemplo sabemos que en los
paralelogramo las diagonales se detectan
entre sí déjame marcar eso entonces voy
a poner que este cachito de acá es igual
a este cachito de acá porque esta
diagonal biseca a la diagonal bb y
además sabemos que la diagonal be device
cada lado
entonces este cachito de acá es igual a
este cachito de acá déjame ponerle un
nombre a este punto vamos a ponerle
a poder referirnos a los segmentos por
su por su nombre vale entonces a es
igual a ese nivel es igual a d
vale bueno entonces ahora cuál sería el
plan para ver qué hace y ved son
perpendiculares pues lo que vamos a
intentar ver es que a b
el triángulo ave es congruente al
triángulo cb y si logramos hacer esto
entonces este ángulo de acá el ave sería
congruente al bs
pero además suman 180 entonces dos cosas
que suman 180 deben de ser 90 cada uno y
por tanto aquí tendríamos el ángulo de
90 grados que queremos vale entonces
vamos a hacer eso y lo vamos a hacer con
el criterio lll observa qué ave ave es
igual abc entonces ahí tenemos un lado
igual otro lado además tenemos que ver
es igual a b y también hay es igual a
ese entonces déjame escribir por acá que
los triángulos que el triángulo el
triángulo ave
es congruente al triángulo cb y al
triángulo se ve que esto de aquí es por
criterio por criterio
de congruencia de congruencia lll lado
lado lado vale bueno ya que tenemos que
estos triángulos son congruentes
entonces ahora sus ángulos
correspondientes son congruentes
entonces observa que el ángulo
corresponde al ángulo cb a este de acá
entonces lo voy a poner por aquí y el
ángulo el ángulo a v a
b es congruente es congruente al ángulo
cb al ángulo c b y esto es porque son
son ángulos correspondientes
correspondientes pero lo voy a poner
ángulos correspondientes de triángulos
congruentes valen triángulos congruentes
muy bien entonces ya casi terminamos
porque ahora observa además de que son
congruentes también son suplementarios
también son suplementarios
es decir entre los dos suman 180 porque
pues es este ángulo de acá sale entonces
tenemos dos ángulos que son congruentes
y que además son suplementarios osea que
suman 180 así que no hay escapatoria
verdad para que dos cosas iguales sumen
180 necesitamos que cada una de esas
cosas me da 90 grados entonces ya nada
más déjame escribirlo por aquí abajo
entonces la medida la medida del ángulo
b es igual a la medida del ángulo cb se
ve y estas dos son iguales a 90 grados
muy bien entonces este ángulo de acá es
de 90 grados este ángulo de acá es de 90
grados
repitiendo el argumento podemos ver que
el de acá es de 90 grados y el de acá
también cientos después está bien padre
porque las diagonales ya son
perpendiculares pero más aún verdad como
es paralelogramo se cortan a la mitad
entonces además de que son
perpendiculares podemos decir que son
media triz es una de la otra